zusammen herzlich willkommen bei zdf
heute live in ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und das problem über das wir heute reden
wollen das wird wahrscheinlich jeder von
euch kennen denn ich glaube fast jeder
hat irgendwie so eine kiste mit alten
handys tastaturen kabeln elektro schrott
einfach im keller stehen die da schon
ziemlich lange steht und die hälfte der
sachen funktioniert auch eigentlich noch
aber vielleicht klappt das mit den
kabeln nicht mehr so richtig mit dem
neuen computer
die andere hälfte ist irgendwann kaputt
gegangen meistens viel zu viel zu früh
oft väter nur so ein kleines teil oder
eine kleine sache dass nur kaputt aber
das zu reparieren das ist zu aufwendig
das ist zu teuer und das ganze zeug aber
zum recyclinghof zu bringen das ist dann
häufig dann muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
wir sind zu viel arbeit
darüber möchten wir aber heute reden
wenn das ist ein riesenproblem wir sind
europameister im elektroschrott
produzieren und wir haben immer noch
kein recht auf reparatur und das
besprechen wir jetzt mit unserer
bundesumweltministerin es werden ja
schulze von der spd mal ganz ehrlich
haben sie auch so eine kiste mit
elektroschrott bei sich im keller stehen
nee ich hab nicht so eine kiste aber ich
weiß dass das ein riesenproblem ist und
dass sehr viele leute sich danach sehnen
dass es endlich mehr reparatur gibt war
das ist auch genau richtig blank an
produkte viel länger nutzen als wir das
heute tun heute ist viel zu auf dieses
kurz nutzen wegwerfen und das nächste
gerät das geht natürlich nicht dass sie
nutzen die geräte länger oder sie
bringen die immer sofort zum
recyclinghof ja ich habe mir angewöhnt
die geräte wirklich zurück zu bringen
also es gibt so systeme da kann man
gebrauchte geräte wieder hingeben die
breiten die dann wieder auf und haben
dann eben noch die möglichkeit das zu
ehren des in den nächsten nochmal zu
nutzen aber das problem ist ja wir haben
es hier gerade unten im laufband
stehende sind europameister im wegwerfen
und im elektroschrott produzieren und
warum das ganze so schwierig ist das
erklärt uns jetzt meine kollegin julia
schröter
elektro schrott ein riesiges problem der
weltweit am stärksten wachsende abfall
zweig
allein 2009 10 fielen über 50 millionen
tonnen an
mehr als dreieinhalb millionen solcher
lkw-ladungen immer mehr geräte landen
auf dem müll
die deutschen sind sogar die größten
verursacher von elektroschrott in europa
ein grund dafür ist dass die lebensdauer
von geräten in den letzten jahren
deutlich gesunken ist
zu reparieren war uns zu groß ist ein
bisschen wegwerfprodukte worden war neu
kostet nicht viel und deswegen hat die
alte dame einfach mal weg
statt zur reparatur wandern defekte
teile heute viel schneller als früher
gleich auf den schrott fernsehtechniker
detlef mango der sich mit reparaturen
auskennt weiß warum
zum einen weil der kunde oft gar nicht
glaubt dass man noch reparieren kann oft
gar niemanden mehr findet der repariert
und zum großen teil bekommen wir von
vielen herstellern gar keine ersatzteile
mehr und dadurch verhindert war
natürlich massiv die reparaturen
die folge der elektro schrotthaufen
wächst und wächst
tja und die frage ist wer trägt dafür
die verantwortung wo sehen sie die frau
schulze am allerbesten wäre es wenn
produkte direkt so designt werden so
geplant werden dass man sie überhaupt
reparieren kann
und das ist im moment bei vielen
produkten überhaupt nicht mehr der fall
man kann sie gar nicht mehr öffnen man
kann sie kaum noch reparieren
deswegen brauchen wir transparenz für
die verbraucher was ist wie welche
haltbarkeit hat das produkt überhaupt
was ich da kaufe was muss die
möglichkeit geben zu reparieren und das
muss man europäisch machen weil leider
wir hatten ein großteil der dinge die
wir hier nutzen nicht in deutschland
produziert ist reicht also nicht in
deutschland regeln zu machen sondern
immer muss den europäischen also im
europäischen markt haben
da sind wir dran wir haben wir auf der
europäischen ebene viel bewegen können
aber es ist eben noch lange nicht für
alle produkte so aber trotzdem da
möchten wir nicht noch mal im detail
darüber reden trotzdem ist es ja so
viele horten die ganzen sachen zu hause
bringen sie nicht unbedingt mit dahin wo
sie hingehören
ich sage diese kiste ja schon
angesprochen und bekenne mich auch
schuldig ich möchte sie nächste woche
weg bringen habe ich jetzt beschlossen
wir verfehlen aber deswegen auch locker
die eu quoten dieses jahr gibt wir
müssen sehr viele sachen einfach
weggeben und das passiert nicht und auch
da haben wir mal ganz kurz ein paar
zahlen vorbereitet
in deutschland fallen jährlich rund 1,6
millionen tonnen elektroschrott an
nur ein teil davon wird wiederverwertet
2018 waren es 43 prozent
der rest landet auf dachböden und in
kellern oder wird aus bequemlichkeit
einfach im restmüll entsorgt der eu
reicht das nicht schon 2009 10 hätten
eigentlich 65 prozent des e schrott
recycelt werden müssen damit das künftig
gelingt sollen ähnlich wie schon für
batterien in geschäften sammelbehälter
für kleine elektro aufgestellt werden
etwa für alte handys oder tablets und an
dem punkt möchte ich mal unsere zweite
gesprächspartnerin dazu holen das ist
johanna sido referentin für
ressourcenpolitik und bei der ngo
germanwatch und vorsitzende des vereins
runder tisch reparatur frau sie doch
jetzt lassen wir mal die reparaturen
gleich noch mal beiseite da reden wir
dezidiert man drüber wenn wir erst diese
rate angucken dass wir nicht genug
elektroschrott zurückbringen wo sehen
sie da die verantwortung ist es der
konsument also sind es quasi wir vor
allem die dafür verantwortlich sind
nie würde ich nicht so sehen nicht darin
will ganz klar es gibt ein elektronik
altgeräte gesetz und demnach ist es zum
beispiel so dass händler produkte
zurücknehmen müssen aber jetzt auch noch
der neuen es gibt das gerät wurde jetzt
noch mal novelliert also neu aufgesetzt
und auch da ist es so dass zum beispiel
drogerien die produkte nicht
zurücknehmen müssen viele produkte
kommen inzwischen vom online-handel und
auch der online handel sagt mich immer
so ganz klar sagt nicht klar und
deutlich dass man auch ihr zu ihnen die
produkte zurückschicken kann oder haben
einfach ein riesen problem mit dem
sammeln quoten und wenn der großteil
schon beim sammeln verloren geht dann
kann man nachher noch viel weniger
zurückgewinnen und wir haben das problem
dass wir nur dass ein smartphone hat und
30 rohstoffe und davon werden 2 3 nach
einem recycling zurückgewonnen das heißt
da geht dann natürlich auch selbst wenn
es dunkel wird noch extrem viel wieder
verloren wenn sie jetzt sagen
online-händler zum beispiel müssten die
ware zurücknehmen da bin ich jetzt
wieder der faule verbraucher der sagt
das alte gerät eintüten in schönes paket
packen label drauf zur post bringen das
ist eine viel zu umständlich sie müssten
deshalb gleich ein schein geben dass man
das zurückschicken kann es muss mehr
informationen darüber geben
auch die andere
an den händler müssen das zurücknehmen
aber da brauchen wir einfach da ist es
da wird erst ab einer viel zu kleinen
verkaufsfläche von produkt verpflichtend
gemacht dass der händler auch die
produkte zurücknehmen
das heißt es gibt erst nur novelle haben
sie gerade schon gesagt in diesem
elektro elektrogeräte gesetz oder
elektroschrott gesetzt weil geräte
gerade jetzt im internet also da das
sollen quasi einfacher werden frau
schulze was haben sie denn da konkret
vor also ich meine das ist ja schon
hürde zum recyclinghof zum beispiel zu
fahren der mensch ist faul und möchte
das am liebsten ja genauso einfach weg
bringen wie batterien zum beispiel
müssen wir einfach mehr stellen schaffen
wo diese geräte zurückgebracht werden
können weil ja wir die meisten sind ja
nicht von sich aus motiviert da was zu
tun obwohl das natürlich auch schön wäre
und deswegen mehr transparenz wir wollen
das stärker bei den geräten man
überhaupt zieht kann ich die reparieren
lassen welche haltbarkeit haben die
überhaupt und ich muss sie an mehr
stellen zurückgeben können weil das ist
heute noch das offensichtlich reicht das
nicht was wir an stellen haben wo man
das zurückgeben kann
und deswegen wird die anzahl der stellen
wo solche geräte zurückgegeben werden
können ja jetzt deutlich wo denn dann
konkret also kann ich das beim bäcker
abgeben die meisten läden in denen man
elektrogeräte kaufen kann also alle die
diese elektro-kleingeräte also alles was
sozusagen sich transportieren lässt was
jetzt nicht gerade eine waschmaschine
ist die das verkaufen die müssen dann
auf solche geräte wieder zurücknehmen
und das heißt es in einer von vier
quadratmetern also ab einer verkauften
das sagst da kann ich mir nicht konkret
was unter vorstellen ist es so eine
typische drogerie von der größe her
großer sozusagen elektrogeräte auch
sonst kauft ein großer markt ok also
schon ein bisschen größer das heißt da
ist die würde auch wieder ein bisschen
höher dass ich das gerät tatsächlich
zurückbringe es gibt ja auch so ideen
von den grünen zum beispiel das pfand
gibt auf zum beispiel ein handy das sich
dann 50 euro zurückbekommen oder 25 euro
warum hat das noch niemand aufgegriffen
in der bundesregierung
das problem ist mit einem pfand system
wie machen wir das mit geräten die aus
dem ausland kommen
wie wie kriegen wir aber keinen
deutschen mag ich kann die deutschen
händler verpflichten aber ich kann ja
nicht alle anderen verpflichten weil wir
in einem europäischen markt aber die
meisten raucher in deutschland ja was
wäre sofort wettbewerbsverzerrung wenn
ich sozusagen den anderen aus anderen
staaten der auflagen mache deswegen wir
kommen da nur über einen europäischen
markt weiter und ich glaube so
pfandsystem für handys ich glaube es
muss einfacher sein handys zu bekommen
die auch reparierbar sind man muss mehr
informationen darüber haben
das ist der entscheidende hebel schon
beim design anzufangen
immer am ende erst zu reparieren das
hilft nicht sondern die geräte müssen
repariert werden und da waren wir über
die über design richtlinie dran aber
trotzdem ist die frage was machen wir
den geräten die halt tatsächlich
irgendwann zu alt sind oder so kaputt
dass sie nicht repariert werden können
frau sieht wo sie haben gerade schon mit
dem kopf ein bisschen den kopf
geschüttelt
ja ich würde gerne einfach die zeit
punkte die sie gesagt die sie rein
geworfen haben könnte es heute genau so
genannt haben den transparenz und das
design nochmal ansprechen weil genau da
sehe ich gerade auch auf der nationalen
ebene große chancen was machen wir haben
den französischen beim französischen
reparatur index den wir auch vom runden
tisch reparatur fordern ein bündnis von
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
umwelt verbraucher organisation
gewerbliches gewerbliche reparatur und
der wissenschaft wie auch die reparatur
netzwerke und wir fordern dass wir auch
so ein reparatur index wie man es in
frankreich hat auch in deutschland hat
damit hat man dann eben die transparenz
um auch kennen zu lernen um zu wissen
wie gut ist das reparierbar sie beide
und die ganze zeit immer schon in diese
reparatur geschichte aber ich möchte
noch mal das recycling reden weil das
ist tatsächlich ein problem wir geben
nicht genug geräte zurück also wir haben
die in unseren kellern die horten die
teilweise landen sie auf den falschen
kanälen werden irgendwie in andere
länder geschickt wo sie dann
ausgeschlachtet werden noch mal zu ihrer
novelle dieses dieses gesetzes das ist
ja jetzt im dezember von der
bundesregierung beschlossen worden ist
durch den bundesrat gegangen der hat
letzte woche eine stellungnahme
veröffentlicht wie das dann so ist bei
solchen gesetzen und der bundesrat die
länder waren auch nicht zufrieden damit
wie das läuft die haben gesagt
die hersteller sollten zum beispiel
durch finanzielle anreize dazu bewegt
werden produkte länger zu bauen das ist
dass die länge langlebiger sind langer
langer halten dass sie besser zu
berechnen und zu reparieren sind aber es
soll auch zum beispiel dazu kommen dass
das geräte die noch funktionieren dass
man die zb bei wertstoffhöfen abgeben
kann in speziellen containern damit die
wiederverwertet werden können zum
beispiel durch spezielle vereine die
dann an bedürftige weiter verteilen
wieso haben sie diese idee noch nicht
aufgegriffen oder sind gar nicht von
selber drauf gekommen frau schulze wie
versuche ich hab container aufstellen
gilt ich musste innerhalb der regierung
dass immer wieder sozusagen abstimmen
mit den anderen ich kann das nicht
alleine entscheiden wenn ich das alleine
entscheiden könnte und nicht das
wirtschaftsministerium dabei hätte was
immer wieder bremst wären wir schon
ganze schritte weiter okay da jetzt
interessant das wirtschaftsministerium
hat was dagegen dass wir container
aufstellen auf wertstoffhöfen wo noch
funktionierende geräte gesammelt werden
das wirtschaftsministerium kümmert sich
immer darum dass das möglichst einfach
für die wirtschaft ist so und das ist
ein punkt wo ich bei meinen verordnungen
immer wieder sozusagen scheitere
deswegen ist das eines der großen
probleme und noch mal das was früher
gerade gesagt hat und was ich auch immer
wieder sage dass wir die produkte
reparierbar machen müssen damit man gar
nicht erst auf die idee kommt dass
sofort wegwerfen zu wollen das ist der
ganz entscheidende hebel und wenn dann
das gerät kaputt es muss es natürlich
möglichst einfach sein es wieder dahin
zu geben wo es weiter verwendet werden
kann das stimmt schon wir heute kann man
es in den geschäften abgeben dass es
meistens der weg den man ja sowieso geht
und wo solche geräte einfach so wieder
abzugeben sind es machen nur einfach
viel zu wenig leute deswegen muss noch
deutlich bekannter werden viele wissen
ist eben noch nicht das ist eben das was
wir mit der novelle jetzt eben tun
bekannter machen wo man die geräte
wieder zurückgeben kann
damit sie auch recycelt werden können
also ich habe ein paar fragen hier bei
uns in den kommentaren
die bewegen sich alle um das recht auf
reparieren
da kommen wir jetzt gleich zu weil jetzt
kommen wir zur öko design richtlinie der
eu
das ist ein schönes wort monster mal
wieder ökodesign richtlinie heißt aber
ganz einfach es soll mehr repariert
werden und meine kollegin julia fliegen
nach fast das mal kurz für uns zusammen
was das konkret bedeutet
damit treten ab märz erstmals auch für
deutschland verbindliche regeln zur
förderung von reparatur in kraft
hersteller dürfen dann haushaltsgeräte
wie wasch- und spülmaschinen kühlgeräte
und displays nur noch auf den markt
bringen wenn sie ersatzteile und
reparaturanleitungen für sieben bis zehn
jahre zur verfügung stellen
außerdem soll die reparatur mit
herkömmlichen werkzeugen möglich sein
kleingeräte wie küchenmaschinen
zahnbürsten töne oder handys sind bisher
jedoch nicht von der regelung betroffen
und das war ein ausschnitt aus der
zdfzoom doku die heute abend bei uns
hätte es läuft oder schon in der
mediathek verfügbar ist also könnt ihr
gleich im anschluss gucken die heißt
kampf den elektro schrott wer verhindert
das recht auf reparatur so da haben wir
jetzt schon eine gute idee großgeräte
sollen einfacher zu reparieren sein
warum denn nur großgeräte frau schulze
das ist der erste schritt den wir jetzt
auf der europäischen ebene durchgesetzt
haben dass tritt jetzt sofort in kraft
aber alle umweltministerin und minister
waren sich einig bei dem was wir
vorgelegt haben nämlich dass das auch
für weitere elektronische geräte gelten
soll dass das für handys geld muss für
alle geräte die wie drucker wie alles
was wir benutzen
ich bin froh dass wir den ersten schritt
jetzt überhaupt geschafft haben und das
ist die entscheidung gibt weitere
schritte dazu gehen das ist auf einer
europäischen ebene gar nicht so einfach
das mit allen zu vereinbaren deswegen
ist es gut dass wir das jetzt haben wir
brauchen aber noch mehr die hersteller
müssen und sagen wie lange geben sie
garantie auf ihr gerät wie lange hält
ihr gerät weil heute kann das kaum ein
verbraucher erkennen ist es ein
langlebiges gerät und deshalb eben auch
wahrscheinlich etwas teurer oder ist von
vornherein klar das wird nicht lange
halten
also so eine verpflichtung für die
hersteller das ist das was wir auf der
europäischen ebene in unserer
präsidentschaft auch durchgesetzt haben
dass das alle haben wollen alle
umweltministerin und umweltminister
haben dass er dem zugestimmt und die eu
aufgefordert so dass auf den weg zu
bringen
das casino sind sie auch glücklich dass
es zumindest erst diesen ersten schritt
gibt das großgeräte besser repariert
werden können
ja genau der erste schritt ist also ich
warte seit sieben jahren an dem thema
und damals ging es schon darum wie man
als produkt also ekd smartphone und so
unter der ökodesign für ordnung bringen
kann und jetzt ist eine studie
aufgesetzt worden und jetzt schaut man
sich das noch mal konkreter an also sind
sehr langsame prozesse aber was uns auf
jeden fall sehr zufrieden erst mal
gestimmt hat das erstmal sich sowohl das
der kommission für ein recht auf
reparatur wie auch das parlament und
auch jetzt der rat unter der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft fördert reparatur
ausgesprochen hat das ist erstmal sehr
zu begrüßen
dann müssen wir noch mal ganz genau
hinschauen wie das ausgestaltet wird und
zwar ob das auch wirklich ein
herstellerunabhängiges recht auf
reparatur wird das ist für uns ganz
wichtig dass eben nicht das wirklich
auch alle als zugang zu ersatzteilen
bekommt es für ein recht auf reparatur
immer ganz zentral zugang zu
ersatzteilen für alle auch leute die
reparieren wollen nicht professionelle
reparaturen sind und wie auch alle
herstellerunabhängigen reparaturen
damit wir langfristig ihre barreto
retten können wenn es keine
wenn ein herstellerunabhängiger
reparaturen kein zugang zu ersatzteilen
haben dann stirbt die reparatur
das haben aus was leider ist schon der
fall ist dh es gibt das heißt das ist
noch gar nicht gesichert dass man
tatsächlich sagen kann wie beim auto ich
suche meine werkstatt aus und geht dahin
die reparieren das wenn man das sich mit
dem kühlschrank das problem habe ich
darf nur zudem und dem zu meinem
hersteller zurückgehen oder zu einer
zertifizierten werkstatt weil alle
anderen können das sonst nicht
reparieren
alles ist auch das problem das problem
ist so was wie ein sachkundenachweis
notwendig also man muss eben der
sachkunde nachweisen aber das können
reparatur cafés zum beispiel dadurch
dass da jemand ist der eben solche
geräte auch reparieren kann und der
dafür nachweis weil es eben ein
handwerker ist oder jemand der das
nachweisen kann
damit kommt man als reparatur kaffee da
schon rein in diesem abend ist mein büro
kroatische hürde so ich komme jetzt mal
zu unseren kommentaren weil es gibt
jedoch wirklich sehr dezidierte und auch
gute fragen zum beispiel von markus
schnitzler an sie frau schulze der sagt
right to repair ist schön und gut aber
wie stellt man sicher dass den reparatur
unternehmen die möglichkeit gegeben wird
an ersatzteile und eine frische
zeichnungen der geräte heranzukommen ein
entwurf der unternehmen vorschreibt
zeichnungen und
ersatzteile zur verfügung zu stellen und
zwar auf elektronik bausteinen ebene
nicht quasi das komplette 800 euro
mainboard wo man alles austauschen dann
wirklich sagt okay nur hier hier ist
dieses ein baustein dieser einen
bordstein den wir austauschen müssen
das wäre hier wichtig das heißt dass das
geht ja schon sehr dezidiert ins klein
klein wurde daran bedacht frau schulze
in der öko-design-richtlinie jahren
gedacht dass es diese ersatzteile geben
muss dass die hersteller verpflichtet
werden
denn diese ersatzteile eben immer eine
ganze zeit zur verfügung zu stellen
das ist glaube ich auch dass zentrale
dass man überhaupt an die teile kommt
und dass man die geräte mit denen man
diese teile dann auch einbauen kann dass
das übliche geräte sind dass man nicht
ein spezialschrauben es hier einen
spezialschlüssel braucht um das gerät
überhaupt öffnen zu können oder um daran
damit arbeiten zu können und das ist in
dieser ökodesign richtlinie auch das
bestandteil dieser richtlinie aber
ersatzteil ist ja sehr breit gefasst das
kann ja auch dieses 800 euro mainboard
sein wo man sich dann überlegt okay für
das doppelt kriegs neues gerät es gibt
da eine liste von von ersatzteilen
tschuldigung genau und das problem noch
ist das sicherheitsrelevante ersatzteile
dann nicht reinkommen und das ist
manchmal dass es manchmal ein problem
dass dann irgendwann ganz relevante
satzteile noch nicht dabei da ist die
pflicht noch nicht das heißt das muss
wirklich auf alle ersatzteile
ausgeweitet werden waren dass da die
hersteller die dollar interveniert haben
dass sowas nicht passiert es ist ja sehr
gut dass in dieser richtlinie überhaupt
eine liste drin ist was alles zur
verfügung gestellt wird also ich meine
meine ökodesign richtlinie auf der
europäischen ebene detaillierte liste
mit der ersten annahmen zu haben welche
ersatzteile zur verfügung gestellt
werden damit davon eben niemand
abweichen kann
ich finde das ist schon ein sehr sehr
guter schritt so ich habe hier noch zum
beispiel fragen aus der community die
sagen ist das schön dass man reparieren
kann dass es auch daran gedacht wird
dass man irgendwann zum beispiel ein
handy reparieren können soll
aber was nützen mir ein smartphone das
zehn jahre unter umständen repariert
übersteht aber keine updates mehr
bekommt da wurde gab es jetzt gerade die
meldung dass der große hersteller aus
korea samsung sich damit brüstet wir
geben jetzt vier jahre lang
die jetzt für unsere handys da fragt man
sich doch in welchen produktionszyklen
denken die eigentlich wird auch
bestätigt auch in welchen nächste
kommentare ganz genau das problem sind
eben die updates meine telefon erhalten
ewig aber ich muss alle zwei drei jahre
zwei bis drei jahre austauschen weil es
keine updates mehr gibt wieso ist dann
noch nicht dran gedacht worden
das ist genau das was wir wollen also
recht auf reparierbar kite heißt eben
auch dass es updates dass es software
gibt das drucker das handy sr weiter
betrieben werden betrieben werden können
weil das ist ja dann praktisch dem die
nächste stufe das ist die reparatur für
den technischen bereich und dass
deswegen haben wir gefordert dass in der
öko-design-richtlinie wenn diese
produkte hinein kommen auch ein recht
auf updates sozusagen verankert ist wird
es nutzt nichts wenn ich das handy
repariere ich kann es dann aber nicht
mehr betreiben weil die keine software
mehr zur verfügung steht
dass das ist auf der europäischen ebene
mitgedacht und das soll eben die nächste
stufe der ökodesign-richtlinie sein die
dann auf eu ebene kommt ja das muss auf
eu ebene sein weil das ist der
europäische markt den wir haben also die
die wenigsten teile werden komplett in
deutschland erstellt und verkauft
sondern das meiste ist wirklich
europäisch und es ist eben auch viel
einfacher mit als europa mit den
händlern zu verhandeln wenn ich einem
großen amerikanischen handy-hersteller
sage wir in deutschland wollen das aber
so und so haben dann ist das für die ein
kleiner markt das interessiert ihn nicht
sonderlich habe das als europäerinnen
und europäer tun dann hat das wirklich
relevanz und dann wird sowas auch
durchgesetzt werden kann aber da hat
frau sogar darauf hingewiesen frankreich
geht dann mit gutem beispiel voran zb
was die recycelte reparierbar kite
angeht haben wir auch einen kurzen
einspieler vorbereitet wie das in
frankreich passiert
hier wurde im januar ein sogenannter
reparatur index eingeführt
wir sind mit der frau zum interview
verabredet die an der durchsetzung
maßgeblich beteiligt war
ladies ja was mit ihrer organisation
stopp der geplanten ob solist sands
kämpft sie in frankreich seit jahren für
mehr reparatur fähigkeit und
langlebigkeit von elektrogeräten der
reparatur index funktioniert so dass der
verbraucher im geschäft eine note bis zu
zehn sehen kann wenn ein produkt zehn
punkte bekommt dann bedeutet es dass es
sehr gut reparierbar ist null bedeutet
sehr schlecht ich kann dazu auch ein
bild zeigen
hier sehen wir zum beispiel eine grüne
farbe wenn es eine gute note gibt und ob
eine rote farbe wenn die noten schlecht
ist eine gute note bekommt ein produkt
wenn der hersteller eine reparatur
anleitung veröffentlicht eine noch
bessere wenn ersatzteile verfügbar und
verhältnismäßig preiswert sind
[Musik]
ich glaube dass der index sehr wichtig
ist weil er den verbrauchern viel mehr
transparenz bietet sie können so nicht
nur anhand des preises und der qualität
des produkts entscheiden sondern auch
anhand dessen ob das produkt repariert
fähig ist oder nicht
der reparatur index ist nur eine
maßnahme in frankreich droht herstellern
sogar haft wenn ihnen geplante ob solist
sands nachgewiesen werden kann
tja also die aktivistinnen in frankreich
haben doch schon erreicht so sind sie
nicht hartnäckig genug gewesen das land
näher sollte ich jetzt nicht sagen wir
aber wir müssen auf jeden fall wir
sollten uns 11 frankreich erst beispiel
nehmen und sollten so ein reparatur
indexplatz auch einführen wir sollten
dann auch gleichzeitig schauen was ist
noch nicht so ganz perfekt noch nicht so
gut an diesem reparatur index in
frankreich was sollten von verbessern
zum beispiel sollten wir stärker auf die
zugang zu ersatzteilen der ist dort
nicht so stark bewertet dann müssten wir
ein bisschen weiter bewerten aber
ansonsten sollten uns dann zum beispiel
darin beispiel nehmen und wir können
noch andere maßnahmen auf nationaler
ebene durchführen wir konnten ein
gewerbe steuersenkung für
reparaturbetriebe machen um sie zu
stärken
wir müssten reparatur vielmehr auf in
die ausbildung integrieren das heißt wir
bräuchten wir müssen überhaupt reparatur
wieder als wir müssen das als ein
ausbildungs fach machen weil die
reparaturen sterben uns einfach weg es
gibt habe niemand melde sich
diesbezüglich weiter ausbildet und das
wissen muss in ingenieursausbildung
verankert werden damit das dann auch
wieder ins design verankert werden kann
weil wenn man gar nicht weiß als jemand
der produkte designt wie wieder was
wichtig für eine reparierbar kyte ist
dann können solche produkte auch nicht
mehr entstehen das heißt das ist ganz
ganz relevant und wir müssen auch im
handwerk eben stärken was reparaturen
durch wird das sind einzelne teile die
wir einzelne sachen die wir auf
nationaler ebene noch machen können
wir können wir sollten auch nochmal
kampagnen machen für das reparieren also
noch das wieder stärker ins bewusstsein
bringen wie relevant reparatur ist wie
wichtig ist es produkte langlebig zu
gestalten
für den ressourcenverbrauch und wie zb
das eben in einem smartphone 30
rohstoffe stecken und allein das gold
die paar milligramm gold die in einem
smartphone stecken schon 100 kilogramm
abraum verursachen der damit wiederum
felder blockiert böden verseucht und
bedeuten ihre lebensgrundlage nimmt und
deswegen genau müssen wir da noch mal
mehr bewusstsein verschaffen und zum
beispiel auch nach wenn man irgendwie so
bei den index aus in frankreich den wir
hier nicht haben da würde ich gern mal
unsere umweltministerin fragen wieso
haben wir noch nicht schieben sie die
verantwortung da auch wieder richtung
herrn altmaier und sein
wirtschaftsministerium
denn wir haben uns sogar einen schritt
weiter gehen ich möchte einen digitalen
produkt passt haben weil wir wussten ja
nicht nur die informationen über die
reparatur möglichkeiten haben sondern
wir müssen auch wissen was es in der
produkt überhaupt verarbeitet und wie
kann man ist am ende eigentlich wieder
fachgerecht entsorgen
und diese ganzen informationen habe ich
auf der europäischen ebene jetzt
durchgesetzt dass es einen digitalen
produkt passt geben soll den ersten
wären wir jetzt sehen den gibt es
nämlich für autobatterien also e autos
für die batterien die dort verbaut
werden soll es so einen elektronischen
produkt passt geben ich glaube dass das
auch genau der richtige weg ist wir
brauchen dort mehr transparenz für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher nicht
über die frage der energie des
energieverbrauches und die frage der
reparierbar kite sondern auch was da
drin und wie kann ich es am ende wieder
entsorgen das heißt sie gehen aber immer
wieder über die eu ebene anstatt erst
mal in deutschland einen kleinen schritt
zu gehen und zu zeigen okay so kann man
es machen und so schneller umzusetzen
ich hab das die europäische ebene da
genau die richtige es war die produkte
eben auch aus ganz europa kommen und wir
damit viel weiter kommen als wenn wir
das nur national in deutschland
versuchen dafür ist der deutsche markt
einfach nicht groß genug und weiß ich
national
das hat jetzt nicht verstanden warum
machen die franzosen dann national die
franzosen können über eine reparatur
index am ende niemanden wirklich
verpflichten der werden wir über das
internet irgendwas bestellt wird zu
sagen das muss aber hier für den
französischen markt anders konfiguriert
sein dass das können wir aber wenn wir
so was europaweit machen
damit haben wir viel größere möglichkeit
auf diejenigen die diese geräte bauen
druck aufzubauen und ich will dass das
problem wirklich gelöst wird dafür muss
man an die dran
die das design der geräte bestimmen gibt
es denn
hersteller frau sieht die sie empfehlen
oder wohl man sagt okay die machen das
schon von alleine oder sind die quasi
alle durch die bank gleich wies therapie
wir haben wir haben im it bereich haben
wir also im smartphone bereich haben wir
das verfahren dass da sehr vorbildlich
ist das zeigt sehr genau das ist ein
ganz kleiner es ist ein kleines
unternehmen inzwischen gar nicht mehr so
klein die genau damit begonnen haben zu
sagen wollen das anders machen und die
ganz genau die ganz klar offenlegen wie
ihr das produkt repariert werden kann
die kriegen auch von fx ist es fix it
das beste repair scoring der fixe dass
eine organisation aus unserem netzwerk
die rabatte informationen vor
bereitstellen und da kann man wirklich
das dann anschauen wie man sich das
repariert und ersatzteile bekommen und
müssen von den großen tonnen
und da gibt es dann immer jetzt in
letzter zeit wurde apple total nudel
jubelt apple ist so toll und die machen
dagegen jetzt reparatur geben jetzt
ersatzteile raus und so aber das war der
wunde erstmal groß gefeiert aber
letztendlich werden nur drei gibt es nur
drei ersatzteile die man bekommt und den
rest nicht und es die reparatur die zu
diesen ersatzteilen kommen müssen müssen
solange schulungsprogramm machen was gar
nicht machbar ist können für einen
reparateur kommt zeitaufwand um auch
zugang zu den ersatzteilen bekommen
deren immer wieder erneuert werden
müssten diese also müsste es eigentlich
mit einem instrument in dem der
reparatur des selbst die das unternehmen
selber bestimmen da für sie die
reparatur gestaltet sieht man eigentlich
das geht es eben so machen dass keine
unabhängigen reparaturen die produkte
reparieren können also ist auf jeden
fall ein negativbeispiel aber genau
samsung und so ist es auch sehr
problematisch an die ersatzteile zu
kommen
apple ist übrigens auch ein beispiel in
der zdf doku kann ich nur empfehlen da
wurde dass man quasi durchexerziert wie
schwierig das ist noch eine frage an
frau schulze aus der zuschauerschaft wo
wir auch gerade tatsächlich das hatten
was frau sido angesprochen hat dass es
mehr handwerk gibt dass es mehr leute
gibt die auch reparieren können da haben
sie auch schon gesagt soll dieser aber
nachweisen können und auch da gibt es
tatsächlich jetzt kritik nämlich was ist
in zukunft geplant um das unternehmen
ohne elektronik meister einfacher zu
machen
auch legal reparaturen an laptops handys
und so weiter durchführen zu dürfen denn
aktuell gibt es da meisterzwang das ist
noch ein
altherr brachte herr althergebracht das
gesetz und das team das findet unser
zuschauer vorjahr 333 hier total der
anachronistischen möchte das
abzuschaffen gibt's da pläne in die
richtung dass man das einfacher macht
eben bei uns die meister ja teilweise
fehlen
nein da gibt es so weit ich weiß im
wirtschaftsministerium keine pläne ich
halte es aber auch für sehr sinnvoll so
einen nachweis wie ein meister zu haben
es ist ja ein sachkundenachweis und dass
wir so qualifizierte handwerker an
handwerker in deutschland haben das hat
auch was damit zu tun dass wir eine ganz
hervorragende ausbildung haben und dass
wir eben betrieben auch vorgeben dass
jemanden mit einer hohen qualifikation
in den betrieb sein muss ich halte das
für das deutsche handwerk wirklich von
vorteil dass wir dieses system mit
ausbildung mit meister eben auch haben
jetzt habe ich in der frage an frau sido
da geht es um diese repair cafés das ist
ja auch so einfach etwas was
ehrenamtliches wo man sich hinwenden
kann kann sagen hier ist das kaputt wer
kann mir helfen
der herr zu fall was mit sicherheit
nicht sein richtiger name ist sagt er
hat den eindruck dass es den
zivilgesellschaftlichen engagement
vermehrt steine in den weg gelegt werden
bei diesen ehrenamtlichen reparatur
treffs beispiel schulter nennt er hier
den fall kenne ich jetzt nicht ist das
ein allgemeiner trend den sie
mitbekommen haben oder ist das jetzt ein
einzelfall
ja das ist ja genau das problem auch was
wir jetzt in der kette sein verordnung
sehe neben dass die die ersatzteile eben
nicht an solche repair cafés also dass
es extrem erschwert wird und dann wird
immer das sicherheitsargument genommen
das heißt die soll man soll keine
ersatzteile abgeben weil wenn man die
ersatzteile sozusagen an ungelernte
leute gibt dann passiert irgendwas und
das ist aber einfach auch entmündigen
man könnte auch einfach sagen man gibt
informationen darüber raus und sagt okay
wenn sie dieses produkt operieren dann
sind die und die risiken unterlässt man
ihm den reparatur selber abschätzen
inwieweit das macht aber die war dass
sich das zutraut und das ist immer ein
argument was immer wieder kommt um den
zugang zu ersatzteilen für gerne per
cafés zu verweigern
und das ist irgendwie reparatur ist
eigentlich so eine schöne sache an der
man so viel lernen kann
sagen immer bis gibt es gibt immer
weniger leute die in die technischen
berufe und naturwissenschaftlichen
berufe geben und aber gerade an so eine
reparatur kann man eigentlich so viel
lernen das kann es aber lernen
instrument und damit auch eine
begeisterung für technik vermitteln von
dem her kann ich das nicht
nachvollziehen und ich denke es ist
extrem wichtig dass alle jeder zugang
also bleibt etwas anderes all gestartet
hat hat ein paar das als grundsatz und
auch das recht auf reparatur dass alle
reparieren dürfen ich sehe meine frau
schulze werden frau sie so was sagt das
ist bei einem zwei jahre streitgespräch
ist ein bisschen schwierig wenn sich
beide eigentlich einig sind aber sie
sind ja verantwortlich für die politik
und ich habe jetzt einfach schon das
wort wirtschaftsministerium gehören sie
haben gesagt das wirtschaftsministerium
hat quasi ein interesse daran oder
versucht die interessen der der
wirtschaft der hersteller durchzusetzen
aber haben die nicht auch ein interesse
daran dass es wieder mehr mitnehmen gibt
die reparieren können weil das ist ja
auch ein wirtschaftszweig noch
reparieren wird ja auch geld einbringen
oder wird dann nur auf die großen
internationalen konzerne geguckt ja bei
der irgendwie sein richtlinie ist dass
am ende des tages immer so dass das
umwelt- und das wirtschaftsministerium
sich einigen müssen und da gibt es
einfach unterschiedliche interessenlagen
das ist aber ganz normal dass es glaube
ich schon immer so gewesen aber das
ministerium zudem an den kürzlich habe
ich das gefühl im recht auf reparatur
ist mir aber wichtig dass das dass das
jetzt kommt dass wir überhaupt
reparieren können dass die händler das
vorlegen müssen dass sie die ersatzteile
vorhalten müssen das ist unglaublich
wichtig weil nur so können wir auch das
verhalten der menschen verändern einfach
immer nur appellieren reicht eben nicht
es muss möglich sein solche geräte zu
reparieren und man also meine
informationen dass auch dass die
reparatur cafés durchaus diesen
sachkundenachweis erbringen können dass
sie daneben
da ist ja jemand der das kann der
sozusagen diese geräte öffnen und
reparieren kann
und damit sind sie auch berechtigt an
die ersatzteile heranzukommen
und das bringt uns einen ganz wichtigen
schritt nach vorne bin ich hier bei uns
in die zuschauerschaft gucken in die
kommentare sich da viel zustimmung geben
für das recht auf reparieren auf
austauschbare akku sim handy ist das ja
auch etwas was der bundesrat zum
beispiel gefordert hat ich sehe bei
ihnen viel guten willen ist das
frustrierend immer wieder sich mit dem
wirtschaftsministerium anlegen zu müssen
und dann zu merken dass jedoch irgendein
längeren hebel sitzen denn die sitzen
gar nicht am längeren hebel das ist der
job der umweltministerin ich stehe
sowohl dem verkehrsminister als auch der
wirtschaftsminister als auch der
landwirtschaftsministerien permanent auf
die den zehn last ist einfach mein job
das gehört zu der aufgabenbeschreibung
dazu weil mein interesse ist natürlich
der klimaschutz der schutz der umwelt
und das muss man immer wieder nach vorne
bringen oder am ende kompromisse
schließen
das ist das sozusagen das normale was
eine demokratie eben so mit sich bringt
foto wenn man jetzt nicht mehr damit
sich abfinden möchte sie wollen auch
dazu sagen 'bitte vorschlagen und zwar
dass wir absolute ressourcen
reduktionsziele brauchen wir haben klima
reduktionsziele für klima emissionen und
wir haben es aber nicht für unseren
ressourcen bereich wir haben immer
wieder müssen effiziente ressourcen
nutzen aber wir sehen dass es immer
schwieriger wird ressourcen zu
generieren es gibt immer mehr probleme
sozialer menschenrechtsverletzungen und
eskalation im kontext von rohstoffabbau
die das wird immer riskanter zu
rohstoffen abzubauen und wir brauchen
absolute reduktionsziele und da finde
ich ganz wichtig dass das
umweltministerium da prozesse anstößt um
über diese absolute reduktion auch
sprechen zu können und es gibt einen
kreis des national resort
ressourceneffizienz kreis und da ist es
nicht mal da würde ich mir sehr gut vom
mut vom umweltministerium wünschen da
auch eine debatte auch zu setzen
mutlos schule das haben wir auch schon
gemacht wir wollen aber nicht nur
reduzieren wir wollen dass die
ressourcen im kreislauf geführt werden
wenn man treibhausgas neutral werden
wollen mitte des jahrhunderts das ist
unser ziel
dann wären wir ganz anders mit
ressourcen umgehen müssen und sie müssen
im kreislauf geführt werden das ist
etwas was wir auch in der eu
ratspräsidentschaft auf der europäischen
ebene wieder vorangetrieben haben dort
gibt es jetzt so ein
kreislaufwirtschafts aktionsplan der
genau die schritte entwickeln soll
wie man ressourcen stärker im kreis
führt weil das wird die absolute
herausforderung sei nicht nur reduzieren
sondern gar nicht mehr einfach wegwerfen
sondern im kreislauf führen aber dafür
ist das was wir eben diskutiert haben
reparierbar kite transparenz mehr über
das produkt zu wissen so einen digitalen
produkt passt zu haben das ist dafür
unabdingbar das brauchen wir unbedingt
damit solche kreislauf geschlossen
werden können kommt aber irgendwie alles
gefühlt ein bisschen zu spät also ich
meine recycling das ist ja ein thema was
wir schon seit 40 jahren kennen
recycling sondern wirklich im um im
kreislauf für recycling heißt genau im
kreislauf das ist das was ist aber wenn
wir die gesamte wirtschaft daraufhin
umstellen will das ist schon mal noch
eine gründe etwas größere geschichte als
einfach nur einzelne dinge zu recyceln
sondern das muss das grundprinzip
sozusagen der wirtschaft werden dass wir
im kreislauf sozusagen wie dem die
materialien die die rohstoffe führen
damit wir eben nicht mehr so viel davon
verbrauchen wie wir das heute tun über
noch ein wort dazu ja also es stimmt zu
wir müssen absolut kreislaufführung ist
essentiell und der neue server compact
auf eu ebene ist wesentlich progressiver
als die wir davor waren es geht nämlich
genau darauf die abfallhierarchie dass
man sagt okay
erst mal ab verströme vermeiden das ist
absolut richtig und dann müssen wir uns
nix progressive umsetzung haben auch
eben in meck at bereich ist im
elektronikbereich und bisher sehr wenig
passiert ist mit bezug auf software etc
aber trotzdem denke ich sollten wir uns
auch messen daran was wir wirklich was
wir wirklich reduzieren im klimabereich
machen wird es manchmal auch nehmen
nicht ausreichend genug oder auch meist
nicht ausreichend da muss aber es gibt
zumindest ziehen und wir brauchen ziele
was nicht gemessen was nicht messbar
gemacht werden kann kann man noch
weniger kontrollieren und wir brauchen
der klare ziele das europaparlament hat
sich dafür ausgesprochen
und ich würde mir das unbedingt auch auf
deutscher ebene wünschen dass wir uns
auch daran messen was wir machen und an
verschiedenen stellen anschauen wie wir
wirklich die primär also die den bergbau
die rohstoffe reduzieren können dass wir
nicht mehr so viele rohstoffe neu
gewinnen werden müssen sondern die
möglichst im kreislauf lassen lassen
dass er kreislauf lassen kann und
insgesamt seinen ressourcen konsum
reduzieren aber es ist ein dickes brett
und da hab ich als seiner verbraucher
oft das gefühl okay ich kann sowieso gar
nichts machen frau sie so was kann ich
denn konkret tun um da und zu
unterstützen und zu helfen und jetzt
sagen sie bitte nicht ich soll ein
kleines verkaufen weil das werden die
meisten nicht tun
ich finde auch wir müssen auch nicht nur
wir sind nicht nur wir können nicht nur
wegen dem wir richtig konsumieren
sondern wir müssen versuchen auch mit
die strukturen anzugehen wir haben wir
uns bei germanwatch in das konzept des
handlings dass wir eben auch selber
versuchen was bewegen zum beispiel auch
versuchen der politik deutlich zu machen
wie wichtig wäre dass finden das was
mehr repariert wird ein ereignis repair
café aufzubauen
dann wird es verschiedene plattformen
auf dem man dass es damit auf der red
arrow konsum geben aber die ist ja eben
auch wichtig dass man ein macher oder
kaputte jeder kann man reparaturen noch
finden um reparieren zu können oder dass
man eben gebrauchte produkte kauft du
musst nicht das muss nicht unbedingt
fair von seien und dass man sich das
nicht das neueste per funk habe das
neueste smartphone kauft sondern ein
gebrauchtes dann reduziert man damit
schon mal aber genau das ist der eine
eben also selber versuchen seine
produkte möglichst lang zu nutzen und
zum anderen dann eben auch versuchen mit
sich für das recht auf reparatur
einzusetzen und dafür brauchen wir zum
beispiel auch auf einer ebene braucht
mit auf rechts in der bundes kaufrecht
muss geändert werden so dass wenn wir
ein produkt zurückgeben dass wir dann
auch entscheiden können nein ich will
nicht ein neues produkt weil der
hersteller sagt für ihn ist es günstiger
neues produkt zu kaufen sondern ich will
ein
ich werde das reparatur das produkt
repariert lassen
und wenn ich noch ein bogen spannen darf
wir haben jetzt gerade wir reden ganz
viel was lieferketten gesetzt das ist
uns ja allen wir glaube ich vielen
vorzügen vielleicht auch bekannt wir
brauchen sorgfaltspflicht wir brauchen
das die hersteller verantwortung auch
übernehmen was in ihren lieferketten
passiert das leider was uns vorgelegt
werden das ziemlich schwach und geht
nicht ausreichend in die lieferkette
auch rohstoffe rohstoffe teurer da gar
nicht mit berücksichtigt weil es einfach
etwas zu tief in der lieferkette liegt
und man einfach sagt wir machen das
nicht da sieht man leider auch gegen die
gegen die uhr enorm auf grundlage der es
eigentlich entworfen wurde
aber wir müssen also wenn so lange wie
die umweltkosten und auch die also und
ganz geringe löhne zahlen werden die
neuen produkte immer günstiger werden
weil wir eben also der arbeitskraft auch
im ausland ist so niedrig dass leute
teilweise nicht mehr davon nehmen können
wir haben ganz viele extra wächst
analysieren die umweltkosten
also genau es kostet nicht die umwelt zu
verschmutzen und dadurch wird die
produktion ist einfach so gut es so
günstig neue produkte zu produzieren und
wir sehen uns dass sie auch für die
produkt der letzten jahren fünf und 34
prozent günstiger geworden sind und
gleichzeitig der reparaturkosten teurer
geworden sind und da müssen wir eben
auch sein wir müssen auch mehr für neue
produkte werden bereits an zu kaufen die
müssen aber voraus sein und dafür
brauchen wir in lieferketten gesetzt was
eben auch da stand aber noch günstiger
ist es halt seine geräte länger zu
nutzen sie sorgsam zu behandeln und wenn
was kaputt geht zu gucken ob man das
repariert bekommt oder vielleicht ein
gebrauchtes gerät zu kaufen gibt ja auch
diese rief erwischt geräte und
vielleicht ja den keller aus zu lernen
dann sind wir wieder am anfang genau da
spart man auf jeden fall auch wieder
gibt es auch hochrechnungen von
irgendeinem verbraucherzentrale als man
wirklich massiv selber geld spart wenn
man produkte lange nutzt so schulz ich
gebe das heißt dass man ihn an sie ich
kann einfach nur noch einmal dafür
plädieren die der geräte eben nicht
sofort wegzuwerfen reparierbar kyte ist
bei vielen geräten schon gegeben und
einfach mit auch selber darauf zu achten
dass man geräte wieder repariert und
nicht immer wieder das neueste haben
muss sondern vielleicht auch so was wie
mobilfunkgeräte und so etwas länger
nutzen als wir das heute tun dass
vielleicht das zweit und dritt neueste
das taugt dann manchmal auch dann sage
ich vielen dank für diese diskussion und
für die impulse ist bleibt viel zu tun
stellen wir fest gerade wir deutschen
müssen noch mehr tun und da liegt es an
der politik aber auch wie immer an jedem
einzelnen damit sage ich danke schön
nach berlin und sagt danke schön in den
stream dass ihr dabei seid gewesen seid
fragen gestellt habt gute diskussionen
gehabt hat aber stellte fest die meisten
sind wie tatsächlich einig da muss mehr
passieren von der politik aber auch von
jedem einzelnen und diesem sinne sag ich
jetzt für heute erstmal vielen dank fürs
dabei sein
macht's gut bis zum nächsten mal